what we have to talk about
is to ensure europe the place
and the role
that is due to it in a
world to be built
this europe will be all the more
attentive to other peoples as it
will be more assured of  male
[Music]
since the origin of the community,
like many of you, I have defended
the idea that we should build a
social Europe, but
today
if we have traced the outline of
social Europe
there  has no content
is it not a work and exhilarating
exciting to put it in
content
[Music]
the europe of cultures ladies and
gentlemen it is the europe of nations
against that of national ones
it happens that the chances of
life wanted my youth during the
first world war
and that I do the second
I therefore lived my childhood
in the atmosphere
of a torn family
who all their help died and who
harbored
a grudge sometimes have news
against the enemy  of the day before
it is necessary to transmit
n  or not this week but on the contrary
the chance
of reconciliations that we owe it
must be said to those who such is the 144
1945 had the audacity to conceive what
could be a more radiant future which
would be based on reconciliation and
on the  press that's what we did
[Music]
nationalism it's
war war
it's not just the past it
can be our future
and it's us it's you ladies and
gentlemen deputies who is now
the guardians of our peace
[Applause]